une journée triste sur grenoble la pluie
a sûrement découragé bien des gens de
s'aventurer au centre-ville
mais selon ce jeune restaurateur le
problème est ailleurs
marouane hamadi aux personnes son petit
casse croûte de la rue béria alors nous
on fait des burgers maison de a jusqu'à
z on est capables de se payer un employé
il travaille 6 jours sur 7 il se demande
si le grand projet de mobilité durable
du maire pionne n'aura pas raison de son
commerce
là on voit un peu d'égoïste pour ce beau
coup son projet mais pas le reste
eric piolle c'est lui le premier
écologiste élu à la tête d'une ville de
plus de 100000 habitants en france
à peine installé en 2014 il s'est
débarrassé des voitures de fonction de
son prédécesseur sous prétexte qu'ils
préfèrent se déplacer à vélo depuis il
prend les grands moyens pour initier des
changements de comportement à grenoble
la question n'est pas de chasser les
ruptures c'est juste de donner de la
place aussi à nos nouveaux moyens de
déplacement n'empêche l'administration
piol à limiter la vitesse à 30 km heure
dans 80% des rues et créer une zone de
circulation limitée au centre ville les
propriétaires de voitures doivent
maintenant se doter de vignettes spécial
selon l'âge et le modèle de leur
véhicule les jours de smog les autos les
plus polluantes ne peuvent entrer en
ville sous peine de recevoir une
contravention
mais ce n'est pas tout une multitude de
chantiers sont en cours pour aménager
des corridors vélo et de nouvelles
places piétonnes la création de sens
unique vise aussi à donner plus d'espacé
aux marcheurs et cyclistes des efforts
de verdissement et des ajouts de
mobilier urbain complète le projet ces
travaux-là cet embellissement là cet
agrandissement du centre ville ils ont
pour vocation et nous en avons la
conviction de permettre au centre-ville
justement de battre plus fort demain le
réseau de transport de l'agglomération
grenobloise le tag déploie aussi des
efforts considérables pour élargir sa
clientèle depuis 2014 le laissez-passer
mensuel des 18 24 ans est passé de 30 à
15 euros seulement
l'objectif est d'atteindre la gratuité
d'ici quelques années
est ce que les choses vont bien monsieur
freyssinet les choses n'ont pas très
bien pour l'automobiliste en france en
général et encore un peu moins grenoble
pour tout dire le vice président de
l'automobile club insiste pour dire que
le développement du tramway est
bénéfique pour grenoble
mais il accuse eric piolle de déclarer
la guerre à l'auto la baisse de
fréquentation du centre-ville serait la
preuve que la mairie va trop loin
je sais pas exactement quelle est la
théorie mais ce que je sais c'est que la
pratique c'est que les gens ont besoin
de leur voiture no mais le maire refuse
de porter tout le blâme et rappelle que
le commerce au détail traverse une
période difficile avec la montée du
magasinage en ligne
a grenoble les principaux indicateurs de
pollution serait en baisse au
centre-ville selon eric piolle ou faut
agir pour contrer la crise climatique et
ville s'adapte aux enjeux du 21e siècle
elles ont été conçues après guerre pour
le tout voiture et petit à petit elle se
réadapte elle grignote de l'espace
public erp grignote de la qualité de vie
pour l'instant marouane hamadi demeure
convaincu qu'il fait les frais des
mesures contraignantes pour l'automobile
il n'a pas le choix d' espérer qu eric
piolle gagne son pari mais rappelle
qu'une multitude de petits commerces
joue gros avec lui je peux y croire je
peux y croire mais attendre si on a
moins d'activité en combien de temps ici
olivier lemieux radio-canada grenoble